let's go next to
audrey from
georgia audrey you are on the air
hi david uh i believe we we've uh talked
before
excellent um but i had an interesting
question for you i was on yesterday when
i asked
so
i was i studied chinese in college and i
was talking with my chinese professor
yesterday now sorry i'm sorry to
interrupt
did you study mandarin or cantonese
mandarin ah okay good
and i came to the conclusion that i
think china is a little bit like
kind of i think we treat them very
biased in our media and especially in
our education
and i wanted to get your take on that do
you think that china in many ways is
sort of like demonized in our media like
if you look in the news it's always
something bad about them there's never
any reports on like
the the good things going on in there
like scientific research and everything
yeah i would generally speaking agree
that there is a i mean listen china is
an economic adversary there is no
question about that but they're also an
economic partner and that's what makes
this so complex on the one hand we have
an economy that for decades has been
based on being able to get cheap stuff
from china that's what it is if we
didn't get cheap stuff from china and we
couldn't quickly get it elsewhere and
had to bring all production domestically
we'd be buying american as some people
say but things would cost dramatically
more and what i see is an asymmetry in
if we want to recognize china as an
economic adversary and along with russia
up there with the us as being in a
battle to be the major of the three
major superpowers that's fine that's
accurate i have no problem identifying
china in that way
but
so many of the people who wildly talk
about china virus and intellectual
property theft and this stuff
seem to not know
or or recognize
that our entire way of life including
the purchasing power that we have is
based on the fact that we manu we get so
much of our data of our of our products
from china and i think it would be great
to have a more balanced perspective on
that
all right and uh
i was more talking about um also like in
education very few people in the united
states seem to know anything about like
the politics or the general like daily
life of what it's like for people in
china they just see that's not super
surprising though that it's very common
that people people in the united states
also know very little about the lives of
people in russia or in japan or in
denmark now you could say well china's
more important to know about for the
reasons you're laying out but it's not
surprising that u.s education at least
at the k-12 level is very u.s senate i
mean like in in u.s education we learn
all about how the japanese and british
parliament and everything works but
there's absolutely no involvement in now
uh other countries such as like how
russia's or how china's uh politics work
and i think it's something important
that we need to recognize if we're going
to have those important
political discussions all over the news
about
you know like china getting rid of term
limits or anything if you're going to
understand that you have to have at
least a basic knowledge of how it works
i agree with you i agree with you
completely audrey thank you for the call
you're welcome all right there is audrey
let's go
next to oh we don't often get calls from
idaho let's go to barbara from idaho
hi david can you hear me barbara i can
hear you fine
or at least i could are you still there
barbara is gone that's too bad barbara
left
i was really looking forward to that i i
would love to know what like what's
happening in idaho it's a very
it's a closed book for me let me put it
that way let's go to tyler from st louis
tyler you're on the air
hey david i'm not eating a sandwich this
time okay good
um
i guess i didn't really have a question
i just wanted to apologize to the pacman
community for subjecting their ears to
that
you listened back and the the sandwich
eating was a distraction during your
last call in other words
oh certainly yeah yeah yeah well listen
i think uh i think apology accepted now
we've we've sorted it out
all right that's all i had to say okay
good but next time definitely mute the
discord blings that would be what the
thing to work on for the next call
yeah there's another one yep
yeah that's
something to do to push to talk i don't
know how to turn that off
i have no idea why my microphone picks
that up yeah all right very good thank
you for the call we've gotten everything
up to date as far as that's concerned
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number you're keeping your identity
private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a 25 a month plan tailored more for
small businesses where you can create 60
card numbers a month and much more
but definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman